[Applaudissements]
qui pose la première question alors
maxime vous êtes d'autoire maman
célibataire ça vous ne vous en cachez
pas depuis combien de temps n'avez vous
pas fait crac crac boum boum ouh là là
là là depuis un certain temps moins de
six mois
vous savez je me préserve pour la femme
de ma vie elle m'attend vous avez dit
que vous n'étiez pas en couple depuis
donc six mois mais vous avez quand même
un peu attention il ya différence entre
les fleurs tenait soir et les histoires
longues
donc je fais bien la différence en vo
maximin a fait ça vous quoi les flirts
d'asseoir ça peut m'arriver lorsqu'il ya
un coup de coeur
et plus si affinités ross là dessus de
nos peuples l'eau